sie mussten wegen der korona
einreisesperren in spanien bleiben die
pudeldame lilly von ihrer familie in
deutschland getrennt sie lebt in
deutschland seit monaten sind sie also
getrennt bild ist bei der familie die um
die pudeldame jetzt weint und dort ist
mein kollege und er hat das pärchen das
sich sehnt nach ihrer pudeldame vor dem
mikrofon und wir sind gespannt auf die
ganze geschichte ja hallo ins studio wir
sitzen hier in schleiz bei der familie
branche und wieder richtig sagt ist
diese geschichte berührt tatsächlich ich
frage deswegen herrsche was genau ist
denn passiert
wir sind am 19 märz von marokko nach
spanien gereist wir wussten schnell
allen reisen wegen koma und der beamte
waren unseren pressen oder an unserem
auto oder papier überhaupt nicht
interessiert er sei unseren hund der bei
meiner frau aufs haus und wollte sofort
den ausweis haben wir hatten ja unseren
ausweis mit und wir wussten ja art alle
impfungen ist kerngesund ist gechipt etc
so und nach den ausweis sich genommen
reingeguckt hat gesagt er fehlt also der
antikörper gäste bluttest der ist nicht
eingetragen was wir nicht wussten der
hund wird sofort in die quarantäne
verbracht der hund bleibt hier und ich
war schockiert ich konnte überhaupt gar
nicht fassen mit mutanten sagte er zu
mir ich habe die wahl
ich habe die wahl entweder das tier
opfern spricht töten oder hier zu lassen
und 1340 euro gleich zu bezahlen
manche wie war ihre erste reaktionen ich
war total verzweifelt ich habe wirklich
einen nervenzusammenbruch bekommen ich
hab da drinne ich habe gezittert ich
hab's gerlind geschrien ich war
tränenüberströmt ich habe nur noch vor
lauter schmerz ich habe den beamten so
angefleht x doc ist gesund mein englisch
in ein bisschen deutsch ich ja ich hab
so was von geschrien und dieses bild
ich krieg es heute noch nicht aus mir
heraus die verzweiflung ist immer wieder
da bin ich ein und sehe ich hab's
schlafstörungen
ich bin fix und alle der hund ist so auf
mich fixiert gewesen ich weiß unsere
lily hat mit stimmt vier tage lang nicht
gefressen wie ist so sensibel wenn ich
bloß aus dem auto aussteigen dann dann
fängt sie schon gleich anzuschieben
sie fehlt mir überall
woher wissen sie denn jetzt das ist
alles gut geht wird sie haben uns dieses
video gezeigt also sie ist dort in guten
händen denken sie sie ist da in dieser
kann ist haben also eine tierpension das
haben wir alles mitgekriegt und die
haben uns auch zwei videos so läuft wie
lilly über die wiese und auch auf
jemanden zu sie ist ja personengebunden
und wie geht's weiter wann können sie
gilt dann wieder abholen
naja also dazu kann ich folgte sagen ja
mich an absatz eingeschaltet weil alle
ärzte die wir hier konsultiert haben
tierärzte der meinung sind der hund ist
ja gesund ezb hat ja dem blut es gut
bestanden kann als es sofort abgeholt
werden und das wurde uns auch von der
administration ein shiraz bestätigt und
der die haben uns eine formular
geschickt ein amtliches schreiben dass
wir also einreisen dürfen und den hund
holen auf den schreiben stehen unsere
pässe besser denn nummer autonummer name
et cetera so und wir sind die grenze
angefahren die spanische grenze und dort
wird mit kalaschnikows so kann ich sagen
empfangen und das papier wurde überhaupt
nicht anerkannt und mir wurde angedroht
wenn ich jetzt noch hier stehen bleiben
und weil ich telefonieren wollte
man wird mich gleich verhaften und ich
bin ständig davon gejagt haben ok also
man sieht es ist eine unglaubliche
geschichte
man kann nur hoffen dass die little bald
wieder zurückkommen zum ehepaar und wir
wären die geschichte bestimmt weiter
fallen